E aí
[Música]
se você já refletiu sobre como do dia
para noite coisa simples do tipo sair de
casa o abraçar um amigo se tornaram luxo
estávamos vivendo nossa vida como sempre
vivemos quando de repente nos vemos
presos por causa de um vírus
mas será mesmo que eram os Livres será
que quando tudo isso acabar alcançaremos
a tão sonhada Liberdade
é bom para começar a vou contar uma
coisa para vocês aqui no Brasil
Praticamente em todas as escolas sejam
elas públicas ou particulares uso do
uniforme é obrigatório
não existe uma série de motivos por trás
essa obrigatoriedade eu não vou entrar
nesse mérito mas eu vou ser sincero com
vocês em minha opinião uso de uniforme é
positivo porque só de pensar em ter que
escolher uma roupa nova diferente todo
dia para ir para escola eu já fico com
preguiça confesso
mas Parando para refletir melhor sobre
os motivos por trás essa obrigatoriedade
se uniforme é realmente bom ou ruim eu
cheguei à conclusão de que ele não é tão
bom quanto ele aparenta ser
o primeiro porque ele só fomenta a minha
preguiça né mas esse é um problema meu
mas mais do que isso até que abrir mão
da Liberdade que eu e todos os
estudantes brasileiros temos de escolher
a roupa que usar Nós também temos que de
certa forma abdica da nossa identidade
e recentemente eu li um romance de um
escritor brasileiro renomado Graciliano
Ramos creio que alguns você já o
conheciam EA sua história narra a vida
de
uma família de retirantes nordestinos
marginalizadas socialmente que não tem
água não tem comida enfim não tem as
mínimas condições necessárias para viver
Oi e a intrigante como uma família que
nada tem caminha sem rumo em meio ao
Sertão nordestino para no fim acabar nas
mãos de um fazendeiro que os pagar uma
ninharia para trabalhar e ainda assim
não cheira da condição de Miseráveis
depois que eu li sobre tudo isso eu
fiquei pensando sobre como é difícil de
entender e mais difícil ainda de
explicar o conceito de liberdade
porque embora eles fossem Livres no
sentido de ter a liberdade de caminhar a
liberdade dada pela própria condição
dele de retirantes Eles não eram livres
porque não podiam usufruir da Liberdade
que tinham bom então dá num certo
momento ele encontra esse fazendeiro se
instalam no lugar fixo conseguem algum
dinheiro sim mas continuo vivendo dentro
da pouca condição dentro da boca
educação enfim nada na vida deles
prosperava para que eles fossem de fato
livres e aí agora nem a liberdade que
eles não tinham da concessão de
retirantes eles passaram a ter
é mas agora muitos de vocês podem estar
se perguntando
É mas o que é ser livre afinal
É sim vai fazer o que desejamos mas é
mais do que isso é ter autonomia
auto-suficiência
esclarecimentos sobre quem somos e sobre
o que pensamos
E desde os gregos antigos arte de pensar
de filosofar eram ser livre Afinal como
diria Renê de carta penso logo existo
você livre é ser humano
a hora mas eu sou o livre Afinal eu
tenho diversas liberdades garantidas em
lei eu tenho a liberdade de vir eu tenho
liberdade de expressão certo mas para
que serve tudo isso sim eu sabemos como
usar ou ainda nós queremos mesmo ser
livres
e no primeiro momento essas duas
perguntas elas podem parecer patéticas
ou até mesmo totalmente incoerentes
Afinal é claro que nós queremos ser
Livres sendo Livres nós seremos felizes
e não há nada de mais importante em
nossas vidas o que a busca por nossa
felicidade
bom então agora eu convido vocês a
fecharem os olhos por alguns instantes e
imaginarem como é a rotina de vocês o
que vocês fazem do momento que acordam a
um momento que vão dormir podem fechar
os olhos
E aí
Tá certo olhos abertos bom Infelizmente
eu não tenho a capacidade de ler mentes
ou a habilidade de evidência Mas eu
creio que a cortina de nós tem grande
semelhança da grande maioria de nós
porque o que acontece é que nós
acordamos cinco alguma diferença de
horário Mas no geral bem cedo tomamos
café da manhã fazemos Nossa higiene
matinal E aí vamos ao trabalho ou aos
estudos Ou agora em época de pandemias
simplesmente abrimos até os nossos
computadores E aí passamos boa parte do
dia trabalhando ou estudando e no final
da tarde nós voltamos para casa ou
simplesmente fechamos a tela dos nossos
computadores
Oi e aí depois de tudo isso nós temos o
nosso tempo livre que supostamente nós
usamos para algo que nós realmente
queremos algo ligado a nossa identidade
é isso significa basicamente que um
terço da sua vida você dorme no outro
terço você trabalha ou estuda ou
trabalha e estuda e no outro terço com
sorte você tem o seu tempo livre
é em suma a isso significa que o tempo
que você tem para fazer o que de fato
deseja significa muito pouco do seu dia
e menos ainda da sua identidade
Ah e não é difícil de perceber o que a
identidade de forma prática e visível
basta olharmos para a ponta dos nossos
dedos cada um de nós tem desenho de
linhas único uma digital diferente o que
muitas vezes acontece é que nós
aplicamos dessa nossa individualidade
para poder pertencer o coletivo ou para
nos sentirmos pertencentes a sociedade
um exemplo que ilustra muito bem isso
que eu tô querendo dizer tá na roupa que
eu tô usando
alguns anos todos gostariam de ter uma
usar uma camiseta do Harry Potter e uma
calça skinny Afinal vai ser um coisa da
moda todos gostariam de ter em seus
armários e poder usar por aí livremente
não necessariamente porque eu acho que
essas roupas ficam bem em mim mas única
e exclusivamente para poder pertencer ao
todo é porque na nossa sociedade o
diferente é muitas vezes não visto e não
aceito e como num piscar de olhos no dia
de hoje usar essa mesma camiseta do
Harry Potter e essa mesma calça skinny
passaram a ser Creed
e novamente Não porque eu cresci e acho
que essa sopa não fica mais também em
mim muito menos porque eu entendi que
estava brincando da minha identidade
para poder pertencer o coletivo o
fenômeno aqui na verdade o mesmo a moda
mudou e o que antes era da moda agora é
vergonhoso
e esse é livre vai fazer o que se deseja
então nós percebemos que a nossa
sensação de liberdade ela é falsa nós
fazemos o que a sociedade e o conjunto
de regras que a compõem os de não não
que de fato desejamos se formos então
parar para pensar nos problemas sociais
acabaremos uma discussão ainda mais
profunda porque não é difícil de
encontrar as pessoas diferentes
posicionamentos políticos ou até mesmo
visões e valores morais diferentes
muitos Na verdade nem tem uma opinião
sobre esses assuntos porque nem tem a
liberdade o suficiente para se expressar
sobre o que é melhor para o mundo É mas
o que tem sorte de conseguir se
expressar sobre o que é melhor para a
sociedade ou melhor sobre o que é melhor
para se evidencia um problema recorrente
uma sociedade que mesmo sem intenção o
primo sonhos à vontade de ser livre ser
grega e isola uma sociedade em que
poucos têm direito a muito e muitos não
tem direito a nada
bom e o que significa final significa
que nós não somos livres e não porque
não queremos Mas por que temos que
escolher entre ser livres e ser aceitos
e sendo aceitos ser feliz isso
é mais será que é possível ser feliz em
nossa sociedade mesmo sendo Livre
é bom como eu já fiz muitas perguntas
muitos questionamentos agora vou voltar
um pouco para realidade
e esse copo cheio de água foi a melhor
representação que eu encontrei para como
eu me senti e por vezes ainda me sinto e
nem a pandemia Porque mesmo mantendo os
protocolos de higiene utilizando a
máscara o álcool em gel
uma mera ida ao supermercado se tornou
um drama em minha vida por que bastava
eu colocar os meus pés nas ruas que a
falta de ar começava e junto dela os
pensamentos do esse
esse eu me contaminar é isso eu
transmitir o vírus para os meus pais
meus amigos para os meus familiares e se
eles forem hospitalizados E se eu for o
responsável pela morte de alguém
inocente
e ironicamente essa doença que tira o
ano as pessoas mesmo sem me contaminar
tirava também o meu AR e junto dele a
minha embora falsa sensação de liberdade
e tirou de todos nós afinal ninguém
queria estar vendo mais de 4 milhões de
vidas inocentes sendo perdidas
abre cada pouco a sensação de liberdade
que tinhamos do pouco sentimento humano
que ainda temos do abraço do carinho do
afeto do ser humano
é mas ora a liberdade é boa mesmo depois
de falar tanto as coisas sobre ela será
que vale a pena lutarmos por ela
é bom em primeiro lugar Como diria o tio
Ben a o homem-aranha com grandes poderes
vêm grandes responsabilidades
é isso significa que você é livre não é
só se preocupar com a sua liberdade Mas
é principalmente saber respeitar e
garantir que a liberdade do outro possa
existir
uma frase que ilustra muito bem isso que
eu tô querendo dizer é a frase do
professor Mário Sérgio Cortella
o que disse a minha liberdade ela não
acaba onde começa a do outro ela acaba
onde acaba a do outro
é isso não significa que você não vai
poder usar a roupa que preferir ou
seguir o estilo de vida que melhor se
adéqua a você um exemplo que ilustra
muito bem o limite do uso do bom senso
da sua liberdade tá inclusive agora no
meio da academia na utilização de
máscaras Porque mesmo que você
intimamente não queira utilizar uma
máscara você é obrigado porque isso
acabou se tornando uma lei Mas eu digo a
vocês acreditem em vocês não estarão
sendo menos Livres a utilizar uma
máscara
é porque além de estar se protegendo ao
sair na rua com uma máscara você estará
Protegendo o outro e desta forma
garantindo convite tanto a liberdade do
outro e consequentemente a sua possam
continuar existindo
e e
e isso tudo que eu disse não significa
que Liberdade ela seja ruim a liberdade
é na verdade ótima deixa o princípio nós
lutamos por nossa liberdade para
transfer em termos a nossa capacidade
é Mas a questão que fica então esse ok
Você livre é bom isso nós conseguimos
entender mas será que é possível ser
livre Como que eu posso chegar a
liberdade qual que é a chave o caminho
que eu devo seguir para conseguir ser
livre
e eu refleti muito sobre essa dúvida em
primeiro lugar eu digo que sim é
possível mas para isso nós precisamos
morrer
o e embora essa minha afirmação possa
ser interpretada pelo viés religioso de
que alcançaremos o paraíso após a morte
estou falando de Renascer morrer no
sentido de abdicar dos nossos desejos
mundanos no sentir mais humanos deixar
as máquinas serem máquinas e fazer com
que nós sejamos mais sensíveis mais
intuitivos que passamos apreciar a
beleza do único do diferente
e deixa que rompemos o saco gestacional
estamos lutando por nossa liberdade
então que tal iniciarmos agora em meio a
pandemia que nos possibilitam perceber
nossas amarras atingir o nosso lado
humano e nos mostrou o que há de mais
precioso em nossas vidas a nossa
liberdade Vamos então reinicializar
obrigado
G1
E aí